the massive migration of wildebeests
across the Serengeti has a huge impact
on the ecosystem one overlooked aspect
has been what happens when the
wildebeest drowned during river crossing
every year
1.2 million wildebeest move across the
savanna consuming more than 4,500 tons
of grass every day in an 1800 kilometre
circuit between Kenya and Tanzania as
they follow the Rings their herding
instinct is strong because even though
being in a crowd leads to stiff
competition for food this part of Africa
has so many lions and other predators
that strength and numbers wins out even
if it means sometimes blindly swimming
towards death almost annually thousands
drown and river crossings often because
the opposite banks are too steep or too
many are trying to cross at one time for
the past six years researchers have
taken stock of the pile up of carcasses
surveyed the parade of scavengers
assisting in their decomposition and
used modeling and chemical analysis to
track where nutrients provided by these
dead animals wind up in the food chain
about 6500 animals drowned each year
some being the equivalent of 10 blue
whale carcasses into the river half of
that biomass is bone which takes seven
years to decay carcasses accumulate at
bends in the river an outcrop annually
they add about 13 tons of phosphorous 25
tons of nitrogen in the 107 tons of
carbon to the ecosystem the nutrients
come in pulses that last about a month
Beach and can temporarily double or even
quadruple some nutrient levels vultures
and storks flock to the site for the
feast and likely move wildebeest derive
nutrients in land after they fly away
crocodiles too are known to concrete
chemical analyses showed that up to 50%
of the diet of local fish comes from the
carcasses when they're present after the
meat disappears the remaining bones
begin to support a film of microbes that
in turn become food for fish and other
river dwellers on the positive side the
wildebeest drownings only involve about
0.7 percent of the total herd illegal
harvesting starvation and predation take
many more
[Music]
[Music]